what does that mean
[Music]
hi everyone i'm neil brennan
this is a podcast that i started two
years ago with my friend bianca
hi bianca how was your wish
i'm gonna wait i want to remember this
blackout you're gonna blind no no i
i went
to the park i went to the park i went to
what's that senile old lady
i ate rice krispie treats
they were sweet go ahead it was my
friend's birthday and she had a
social distance park party okay hey
and it was fun it was nice it just felt
a little no masks
uh
when you got close and then when you're
on your own blanket when you went at the
end of the story you'd put the mask on
when you really needed to lean in um
no so that was nice that was just it was
nice it was the grass the blanket
i've noticed i did two stand-up shows
this week
i noticed that it's great to be outside
all that stuff but i've also noticed
that it doesn't take long for me to get
impatient in the exact same way i've got
a patient
a year and a half ago what are you
impatient about just people
just p like people not moving or they're
one of the shows like a gate and then
people won't close the gate and i'm like
would you close the goddamn okay we'll
go
right back yeah i don't believe we're
gonna be
i think some people will take away you
know those old ladies that
don't throw out anything because they
were raised during the great depression
there'll be some people that's me go
ahead we'll start the clock please
we'll start your club um so yeah so i
think there's gonna some
there's gonna be some people would take
away but i find
once the oppression is lifted
there's like a bla there's a baby i just
find it takes so little time
yeah there's a backlash so there's a
like oh the pendulum swings the other
way for a second
back to normal like the the the roaring
20s were
i mean one of the explanations is
because it was after the flute pandemic
right um
to which i say maybe i don't know if
that
i don't i don't think anyone
who is
i i'm of the mind that more people
realize they were introverts
well the problem is in the from 1918 to
1920
life kind was just suckier so we can be
in our homes and have
phone we have some access to the same
[ __ ]
so it's it's not that big of a
discrepancy whereas i think
if we they were all in solitary yeah
and nice it was awful it was yeah
a colorless room they basically
had no taste they had no smelling taste
and no color no taste oh no and they
yeah
um yeah bad news
um um yeah so i think it'd be way worse
you think that yeah that that their
quarantine was way worse than our
quarantine wayward and
a lot of people died that might have
been the thing
that if if the roaring 20s was inspired
by the flu pandemic
seeing 50 to 100 million people die
worldwide must have been like
all right okay
they're not complaining about this life
of short thing okay here we go
now with that in mind
and we've talked about this before i
don't
know how much differently i'm going to
live my life as a result of this time
you're quaran teen boy you're a little
bad boy you're quarantine boy yep
cause what are you going to do
i wonder i mean a lot you're going to do
different
[ __ ] different than before yeah no
well that's what i mean like i don't
know if it
the new lease on life thing i think is
debatable
yeah no i i want it to desperately go
back
i think that's the thing i like you but
you
live kind of a solitary life so
has this been that trying on you no
i've never i've flourished
it's the best i'm hoping i'm actually
rooting against the vaccine
quietly um no but i but i wonder
i wanna i do want the freedom
i want my freedom freedoms i want my
freedoms but i don't
i don't think i'm gonna do ah maybe it's
maybe i mean i've cut a lot of people
off during pandemic
i think because you used to say before
or a few years
before the pandemic we were talking once
and you said you made these declarations
i'm not
ever going to another party yeah yeah i
think you would go to party uh
i think that's i have some bad news for
you
i got some bad news for you tell me i'm
gonna read i'm gonna re-re-state my vote
double down
i will never go to an i don't think i'll
ever go to another party i really don't
it would take what the heck because i
don't it's it makes me anxious
okay well that's good but is that just
do you have social anxiety uh because
you don't seem like you do
no i don't have social anxiety i i
it's i i just i
despise i shouldn't say to surprise i
load
small talk and like hey
poppy pop be the guy that doesn't small
talk
of course that's who i am okay and then
people go this is getting deep and i'm
like i don't care about
[ __ ] what you're
i don't care i've seen you at a party
but it's always people you know
so you know yeah what part have you seen
here oh you sent me the march one
no what i've seen you in multiple
parties he went to a party once
your friend off of melrose there's a lot
of white liberals
i don't remember it was the widest
liberalist party they
do podcasts they're nice oh love it
and ronan pharaoh yeah yeah um
yeah so that there you go and you were
being great
well i'm not saying i'm not charming oh
yeah don't
you come on look i'm not what i have to
be i like a comedy
hey hey hey hey hey yeah and you do hang
out you do yeah i don't know i just
i'd rather just eat with one person
dinner parties two people okay two
people okay that's the one that's
it four i get i might i get hives and
they slowly build up my chest
um what did i do great question did two
shows
and i've been
pre-setting my internet
limits uh with the freedom app i
so now every day from noon to five i
have no internet
and it's forced me to read and write
it's forced me to
basically be in the flute pandemic of
1980 and
what have you written just oh jokes
yeah so um it's uh
it's so much i i just what a waste of a
day
no i don't mind writing or eating so
much so during the day you do you do it
outside at least
no but i do i have started like rock is
staying nearby so we've been taking
walks
which is cute you guys are she's pretty
cute grumpy old men
yeah two two retired cops um
and we take walks and
uh and i've been walking just to like
ride ate
things that i used to drive to i'm like
during the walk the funniest thing
1.6 miles you guys went to the grocery
store that's so funny
that's the best and he was we talked
about
me and rock went to the grocery store
and at one point i looked over
and rock was leaning on the oranges
but had with his hands on the oranges
not
having any idea what he was doing and i
didn't have the heart to tell him
how bad it looked because i because i
bring the pain
um so i i can't i lose my voice
um anyhow did you see the
week wow are we
to quote john love it what a week um
as somebody who lives in california and
many of my friends moved to texas
because it's a better run state
um i believe the internet term is you
hate to see it
you hate to see that uh
a better run state is uh either
faint praise or an oxymoron you pick
it's either like what do you do it's
it's just a different
poorly run it's a different way to run a
state
improperly right uh and
and the weather and the climate change
and the it's a real
look it was i don't want to say it was a
whole vindication for me
was it a little satisfying well no i
don't i actually not the people people
i don't want people to be without power
but i just like when they're just one
whenever it's it's the the way the world
works is the
anytime you say the
you know what's great about this place
blind it's gonna not
the opposite's gonna happen right it
automatically
i remember a friend of mine saying you
know what i like about this girl
she's got a job and the minute i heard
it i said
you know she just got fired the minute
you said that
like you the thing you like is what's
going to go away
so you know what do you what are your
feelings about texas
do you have any broad feelings about
texas um
well they're so quick to
you know secede and
don't know there's never been a cockier
state than i mean there's
it's they're very cocky they're their
own category of
arrogance where it's just insane right
it's insane
but what are you talking like it's
they're like the guy with a small dick
who's constantly talking about like i
delayed some pipe last night like
um yeah it they're they're so arrogant
about being from texas yeah and it's
like
we're from california yeah pretty good
pretty good state
i mean we're pretty chill about it
you know what i mean so i california the
difference in california and texas
uh california is i
they did a study where they saw that
people who um how could you have
possibly brought that sound effect
and what happened to it uh the people oh
now you'd close with it all right i see
what you're doing it's still wrong but i
see what you do
um but at least it's visibly wrong
instead of the invisible wrongness you
normally bring to the show
um couldn't remember to start the clock
at the beginning how could he possibly
remember
he had to hit one button he had to hit
record he's not going to be able to hit
he couldn't possibly have you well
you need a protocol sheet of like
okay like pilots like a checklist
there's a i have a book called the
checklist manifesto that i'll give you
um
you'd think will would learn being
around someone as fastidious as me and
he's
actually gotten worse he's regressed um
now
the study was people in other states
believe
that people in california are happier
than other people
i think we are i i would argue that we
are
california is so like the weather's so
nice out here
you almost can't talk about it it's like
rude to talk about it
they make fun of us when it's windy and
like i will know i know
we are [ __ ] well of course we were
opposed we're it's [ __ ]
perfect when it was when it was very
windy last week yeah oh that also
happened last week
high winds and see that's only in
california is that worth talking about a
podcast
oh that was so weird and i just loved
him i almost didn't make the podcast
we cannot talk about our high it's just
yeah it's like our
problems are not real problems that we
can't we're like the rich it was like
what america is to the world california
is to america
yeah i mean we have a thing called santa
ana winds which
are warm winds from the desert that warm
up
but they're like 35 miles an hour so
it's it's really scary
it's really scary and yeah they're 78
degrees
they make yeah between 75 and 90 degrees
in the middle of winter the one of the
nicest memories of my life is the first
time i experienced santa ana
i love them so when i was walking along
sunset in 1990 something
you know how i am uh my story things
happened a long time ago
um and uh they're so lovely
and we can't talk out of another
premiere i went to
summer of sam i'm an old man i tell you
i'm an old man that john leguizamo
yeah amongst others uh 98
uh so texas has the
they're they have to brag about it
it's if it were great they wouldn't talk
about it yeah
it's like where people don't talk about
cocaine
they'll have they'll tell one person
they have coke but they don't tell
everybody
uh california's got cocaine is my point
there's a metaphor in there i think it
got lost i got overwhelmed
i got so overwhelmed uh and ports had
crews
he was trying to be a good dad uh
yes and trying to be
trying to be a good dad and
it's just a piece of [ __ ] i mean it's
just like he's just a piece of [ __ ] like
even if he's salvaged already but
texas is gonna have to be like all right
man i don't understand
why you would i guess he votes for them
so he gives a [ __ ] he votes for what
they want
he does but ev this is even texas
thought well that's it's like what myths
does texas tell about itself
that that what he did is not one of the
tech like
you know how we are right in texas right
when there's a storm we run to puerto
rica
puerto rico uh or cancun
canned good um we don't pronounce
nothing right
um the so yeah he's just a piece of [ __ ]
and
quote al franken uh um i like
ted cruz more than pretty much anyone
else in the senate does
and i hate ted cruz ted
cruz um so uh rest in power king
for real he also though texas
why are they so against
i know they have this lazy fair
traditional republican like get the
government out of my like how things do
it states rights but
i don't get why it has to be on
everything it's just it's so petty
they're because legislation is petty the
story they tell themselves
it's literally just like we don't get
the federal gov they ignore
all of the federal government benefits
they get
right which is a lot of their budget and
we don't see right here we do nope
you're entirely tied in the federal
government and
stop it just stop it it's like their
whole thing of like i need a
giant truck right to carry around my hay
meanwhile no one's using their [ __ ]
the beds of their truck they just have
it for show and i need a hat
and boots because i might have to stomp
some an ox later or whatever
um and they it's just the myths they
tell them i've been lit i was listening
right before we started to a ezra klein
podcast
uh about it the subject was the
price we all pay for racism basically
the woman saying
that because of racism
like white people pay what like for
instance the
the best example is montgomery alabama
55-65
1955-1965
once black people had more rights the
city of montgomery
closed their parks and recreation
department and
sold the animals from the they just
didn't want
if black people were going to use it
they didn't want to have it yeah
and it's it's like there's something
akin to texas where it's like
we don't there's the myth we tell
ourselves
about how and then white people claim
uh it's the thing i've been saying uh
that if if there were no black people in
america
obamacare would have been passed a
hundred years ago like um
they've proven it's just the what does
it cut your nose off to fight your face
if if i can't no if you're gonna no one
can have it
yes why yeah blind people can't go to
the zoo
yeah kids can't go to the zoo well you
might run into some blacks
just like [ __ ] okay that's a long
time ago but there's more
recent examples but tons of recent
examples of course and
texas would rather
it's there's there are people in texas
who believe that it's
worth what happened with the power grid
just so we don't have to deal with the
feds
yeah and it's like okay this is the only
time
i died buddy 40 something people died i
know the
the child that just froze to death was
so awful i'm like
is what is really worth it i mean i do
think though if you do live
in a southern state it's not about
taking care of people
do you see the email the thing the guy
wrote
before he resigned which that's really
how they
feel it's about taking care of people
but acting like it's your it's fearsome
he said we it is not our job to take
care of you right but what i'm saying is
but yet the federal but they get half
them are on medicaid
oh of course and they don't realize that
it's like that well the amount of
farmer subsidies that we give to
is just rough uh no one owes you
you are your family all right so it's
six words and one is misspelled
like right there the whole thing should
just be erased
uh that's tim boyd is that who you're
talking about yeah
um he wrote that and then resigned from
some position
that oh that you're no we are all
survivalists i mean that's what that's
that thing about you want to see small
government
native colorado city uh
yeah if you want to see small government
look at rwanda small government
yeah it doesn't work doesn't provides
nothing
but it's it's small so and that's their
thing i'm like
i want to tell myself i'm the type of
man
who lives in a small like do you want to
live in
savage town because i just don't at all
right
i don't at all i want paved roads and i
want infrastructure and
and i want a bath you know what i want
we know
um so ice cream so uh
also i don't i think we take for granted
just how [ __ ] complicated creating
this country was
and how many
um theories and ideological arguments
they had to make of no but if this
what happens is then a little it's not
easy it wasn't easy and so
there are just parts of the government
that function
better than other there's parts of our
government that function better than
other governments in the world and
that's why we have them and
they i feel like some people just equate
all the government is bad i don't
[ __ ] like the government i think it's
poorly run there's not a really good
example
maybe in i don't know iceland yeah i
mean there's a smaller nordic
yeah all the the finland uh norway all
that all that that belt is good
it's good but they also don't have uh
as many they don't have black people
there's not as many
uh racial issues i just well they once
they let in
the refugees they started having that
and then it like kicked
so i just don't get the i understand why
in texas and south and people don't have
these issues but they showed the
this town that's on the border of
arkansas and texas and
one side right yeah so what the [ __ ] is
going on in texas when one
arkansas is doing better than you well
you know
it's republicans love saying
government doesn't work elect me and
i'll show you how
like that i'll prove it to you and elect
me and i'll prove it
and then they get elected oh this is my
filibuster and [ __ ] we gotta go and
break and i'm on to cancun we're going
to cancun
um rest in power king
texas well of course but more so rush
limbaugh
oh hello you know what can i tell you
something
can i tell you something go mandela
effect
i thought he died last year i
thought he's been dead this whole time
because didn't he get honored by trump
yeah what is it the rainbow yeah the
announcement comes out
he announced that he was sick then he
got the presidential medal of freedom
yes the rainbow one but here's the thing
about presidential men of freedom you
don't die in your sleep that night
no no um i don't know why i just
thought he died and i thought you should
have said something you should that is
how it should work
and you go like i'm not ready for it and
then they give it to you
and then you die so when he died i was
like this [ __ ] already died
mandela effect
thinking about the metal and then death
when they when i guess they don't really
put people to sleep but they know when
they pull the plug
yeah on people i feel like there's i
guess they give people morphine
but they should also have like
a video from a celebrity wishing them
good luck
something fun to go with something like
if we're so can
i believe that there's a over over uh uh
too large amount of concern paid to
people's last moments
like he was i know he wasn't in pain
i don't i think i've said here like if
i'm in pain
or not or i i i don't think that's going
to indicate my life
[Music]
i don't i don't think that's an indie
i'd prefer to be get
my dick suck who wouldn't
want to be getting but i'm saying in
cancun
yeah but i'm saying from i i just don't
think it's a barometer of a life
or not think of our relatives
our relatives yeah go ahead oh you want
to start this oh okay
you will lose the king of the mumbles
you will lose the mumble in the jungle
go ahead um if you think about your
relatives you wouldn't
it's more for us we don't want to think
that they suffered when they were dying
yeah it seems cruel actually oh i don't
want them to suffer
uh but if we don't want to suffer we
should figure out a thing
that makes their last if we know it's
like
do it like a countdown like 10. it's a
ball drop
yeah so it's an exciting thing for them
death drop something in the dragon
something
something positive some a party at
something
if we're actually concerned a death
party
yeah i mean i'm of the mind that of like
it's the smell your flowers thing yeah
and and
if yeah that's fine if you're if you're
a terminal and we know it's not
obviously you can't do that if
you don't know but the terminal
illnesses i think that's cool
i think it's a way to look at it in this
country but there's certain places that
have the body on display and make a
party
yeah so yeah what do you want me to do
for you
um i guess
if we're true we need to figure out a
protocol an end of life protocol
okay for people so that there's some
uniform
positivity because i don't i i how many
people do you think
die
suddenly versus just
ball parking i don't think most people
die suddenly yeah i don't either
i'm gonna go 80 percent like
yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm not shocked
right
versus like what neil look out right
duck yeah uh yeah no for sure
so now here's we're talking about rush
limbaugh if you're just joining us
um uh here's what i'll say about rush
limbaugh
i there was a vox podcast about his
how he his origin story yeah do you
remember morton downey jr
from the 80s and 90s he was uh he was
is he related no uh really
no were you to robert downey yeah no
robert downey there's a robert downey
senior
oh yeah morton downey jr was he was like
a talk show he had a talk show host in
the 80s
that was a combo talk show
like oprah phil phil donahue
oprah sally jesse okay and like
sideshow like real
wacky so like add in um
like a lot of white supremac like he had
a regular white supremacist like the
you'd know their name like there was a
it was a it was a real sideshow
he got sort of finally like jerry
springer worked
like so much yes but jerry springer is
like a civilized version of morton
downing
wow yeah i want to watch this [ __ ] it's
there was a documentary it's good
interesting uh it's not like great but
it's
pretty good did you watch the show yeah
because i was like eighth grade it was
perfect
it was just stupid yeah it was dumb and
like all right let me tell you something
it was like wrestling yeah so
anyhow he got cancelled and then rush
took his time slot
and before that he had been a
he was a sports guy he was a rod he was
just a
classic rock rush limbaugh was like a
classic rock guy
and then he took over martin downey and
kind of just
did it but more sophisticated
and um and uh
and i'll say this for rush limbaugh an
amazing broadcaster
a a virulent person
but in terms of just his voice and he
would say like
talent on loan from god that was his
sign off
or his like sign in or something yeah um
an amazing literally one of the best
radio people that's ever been
a total garbage person completely
disagree with everything he said
technically a perfect specimen
for how to be a broadcaster and i that's
why i listen to him
every night before i go to sleep this is
uh
and then he also made it incredible he
made uh
85 million dollars a year oh he was
loaded
yeah uh he signed an eight year 40
million dollar deal
that's though i'm sorry 400. they're
jesus
yeah you missed a zero oh my god by the
way speaking of
zero the guy did the gatorade spot with
that fernando tatis the young
yeah guy with the dreads he signed a
16 year 16 years look at it look up the
numbers
to do a sports junior that one says 16
to do sports yeah to do sports
what does he do baseball yeah okay
that's makes sense
kind of 340
for 16 years
and i asked him i go are you still on
your rookie deal and he's like yeah and
i go are you getting an extension he's
like
they're talking about it oh he played it
cool
he signed the biggest contract extension
it's the third biggest in the history of
the game
how why would how is it beneficial
to someone in the like if you're the
owner
i don't know but how is it beneficial 14
years i mean people get injured
i know baseball no i know it's so it
makes sense but not
i mean not that much less like not he's
gonna get injured probably um do they
owe him that money
[Music]
not smart i don't know why they signed
those deals i truly don't it's like
they're trying to send it here send a
message to the league or something what
if he got
canceled i mean can't again if he gets
canceled
if he maybe he stop maybe does ayahuasca
and falls out of love with the game
there's
so many things can go wrong and we're
gonna do iowa
uh yeah so good for him rest in power
king
no but you know what's funny about rush
limbaugh that's when
when obama got
osama uh that was a one time rush
limbaugh actually praised him
he said great job true american for
doing that
and his listeners ripped him they're
like what the [ __ ] are you he was the
one who
routinely would call chelsea clinton a
dog
yeah so he tried to even praise obama a
little bit
i don't know the thing that i didn't
that i like underestimated about him
was he thought he was funny
he like started as like a radio like he
used to do uh
he would say if he didn't like someone's
someone on the
phone a caller he would go i'm aborting
this call
and a vacuum sound would play and you'd
hear screaming
uh which is funny it's awful but it's
funny
that's but that it's just funny comedy
whether it's funny enough
the these guys that make so much money
off of just pandering to the right
people yeah
like like he said i'm not in this i'm in
it for the money
yeah at least that to me great bill
o'reilly you're in it for the money
tiger carlson you're ready i don't well
those guys are a different thing
why what do you mean what's different
about this i believe bill o'reilly
i'm bill o'reilly's been conservative
i'm not saying that they
are secretly not conservatives i'm just
saying
you know you we have left-leaning
principles and like world views
but we're not like clowny left-wing
people
right and if we just hammed it out like
super hams
and we made hundreds of millions of
dollars there is no way to do that as a
liberal
yeah it's something you can't the far
left i mean rachel does
makes very good money well to be his
version you have to be
there's more bombast in right-wing
politics because it's meaner
yeah it's all me whereas liberal
politics are based on
the idea of decency and kindness whereas
republicans are like we need our own
power grid
come hell or high water i'll be in
canada but
uh an amazing broadcaster and
uh a real piece of garbage
um and of and but but if you love drugs
no one loved him more than him
he had like a horrific vicodin
like 70 a day or something like a rapper
like like he's gonna go i mean he was
like
an incredible amount of drug addiction
just drugs he has no he has his own
there's
its own paragraph in his wikipedia
2003 limbaugh was being investigated for
illegally obtaining
oxycodone and hydrocodone
but you know do you know what no one
ever points out how great that must have
been for him
to making 80 million dollars a year high
all the time you think it was high doing
the show of course you're not
you don't go well i'm gonna take
obviously you can't get the [ __ ] out of
your system
like well i you know and there that's
sacred time when i need to be
energetic and performing uh no just
[ __ ]
gacked and making 50 million dollars a
year on a private jet just like
book how is that possible which part
just the fact that you get to be like so
[ __ ] high and make so much more money
than most people
the world's unfair it's not fair the
world's unfair
but in some ways it's funny unfair
that's funny
yeah it's funny that it's so wrong it's
funny it's like that's [ __ ] funny
um speaking of which carl hart has been
getting
flack he was my buddy the the
uh professor who does heroin
um yes he was like in the new york post
this week like they're finally hitting
him with like
you know this black guy does dry and the
picture in the washing in the new york
post is so [ __ ] funny
uh will will you type in new york post
carl hart
thank you and now hit images
uh no uh nope go back
yes the photo like what are you gonna do
arms wide open yeah like what so what
yeah i do heroin
for work-life balance which is that he's
his shoulder shrug emoji
yeah and he's doing that yes he's done
the black shoulder stroke of movie
emoji um and uh but i knew it was just a
matter of time
you think they're gonna get him i don't
think they're gonna get him
he's like really analyzing and he's
talking about it
no no i know it's not a problem but
if the cops want to if the cops feel a
certain way it's just
it's it's like a it's a very
i don't think it's reckless i think it's
brave
he he's doing it for what i believe are
like the right moral reasons to go like
i use drugs i am fine right
what so i would like to get that story
into the news but the way they sell is
like
this black guy does heroin yeah um
so that's you're relying on white people
to tell a
black story in the right way or a story
in the right way that doesn't serve
their needs
anyhow moving on did you you remember
crystalia
[Music]
yeah that's it was uh that was earlier
in the summer
that was that was heavy in the summer
that was we were not doing good
on all fronts june july was george floyd
and delia
it was like yeah may june um
july some this summer i think people
know what we meant when we said summer
well i got specific
uh he released a video
and um and he
took his dick out in the venom kidding
um
he released a video uh the other day
saturday and uh
and what did you think of it
um i thought
that a person in his position doesn't
have many moves
yeah so i thought that was the best
move he could make yeah how like you
know no one knows really how to deal
with this
yeah even the pr drops you if it gets
too big for them
you know yeah and they're supposed to
handle this there's no olivia pope out
there so
yeah i don't know what's the right move
yeah is it just making a a video to
address everything and not hiding i
don't know
but i have it just came out so i'm not
sure
it's in essence it's a hostage situation
or uh or
uh it's a it's a gunman
it's how should a gunman a gunman or a
gun
man a texas gunman this friday
um the uh
howdy it's a standoff it's like a
cultural standoff so
what as if you're the guy in 2021
and you've been accused of uh
sexual misconduct
how do you
what's the right way to do it that's
what you're saying so and
and i watched it and was like
ah i don't like seeing him
play that note in life
like the amount of i've never seen him
that i've spent
a lot of time with him that's the most
serious
i've ever seen him that's more that's a
hundred times the amount of serious
moments in that video than i've in the
15 years i've known him
just way more serious of course but as a
person who it's like
uh it's like watching a clown take a
test
or something it's just like i don't want
to see a clown like
you don't want to see anyone do anything
outside outside of what i like
doing yes um this was sad though because
it's like i don't wanna i don't wanna
see
that guy who i who is like
kind of just silly someone's the first
comment
someone wrote i'm here for silly goose
time which is [ __ ] funny
uh and he didn't because he didn't get
any it was the opposite of silly goose
time
um it was uh serious
serious time um and uh
so but he had it's you gotta say it
there's nothing i was talking to
somebody about
um
taking a harder line it's like bird did
the joke about
tiger woods being like yeah i [ __ ] he
should have been become the bad boy of
golf and like had
chopped off his sleeves but notice how
everyone who's
ever been in this position because it's
a very rare position it's almost like
have have you ever been a talk show host
not most people have never been a toxic
okay so most people have never had that
perfect storm of
some sort of mis behavioral misconduct
and
getting canceled and being famous and
right
so of those people no one's ever doubled
down yeah everyone on the outside is
like shouldn't done
and it's yeah and the amount of people
who are like i'll never apologize
i would never do you know who kind of
doubled down
charlie shane and you know what got him
aids
no i mean checks and balance no i mean
he double he was
one of the only ones who who literally
went on tour
based on a manic episode like not only
am i gonna not
apologize for it come see me do it right
live
no for sure and i i he's pretty
unscathed
he's in a commercial yeah and that's
when i'm like
you were at one tenth of your behavior
and you're black
you're r.i.p king yeah but because
you're charlie sheen
he's in a [ __ ] like health commercial
with his father
yeah if you're black you'd be a janitor
at a hospital
um so i don't know we give charlie sheen
a major pass even though one could make
the argument
if exposing people to aids is
oh i mean it's tempting
yeah nothing there's nothing good can be
said about it
the i have nothing good can be said
about charlie sheen's behavior
people have been canceled for a lot less
than charlie sheen but also i do feel
like the
first person gets a pass like
i don't know i i i i think there's a few
things i it was
10 years ago and it was a long 10 years
in terms of appropriateness
and he was the first one to really the
longest ten years of my life
it was he was the first i just think
i don't know we give a pass to the first
people he was kind of the was he am i
tripping
no he wasn't the first guy to be an
[ __ ] no that's not what i'm saying
the first guy to kind of get the like
attack them all back and he kind of won
yeah because
we didn't know what he cared about
yeah but we didn't know what we cared
about then we sure didn't
look at us now um you're just like
not good behavior yeah but not but it
wasn't
that wasn't the mob with charlie sheen
what he was just being and this is
before aids this is before he was before
he was by winning i'm
winning yeah winning and tiger blood and
it was [ __ ] he had hooks the guy
wanted everyone
episodes um i don't even know what
what the backlash would i think that
maybe the show the two-and-a-half men
was involved
no but that happened he had the fx show
where it was like
group therapy it was what no he what did
he
he did something that everyone got
obsessed over maybe it was the
he had those girls on the videos just
those two girls the angels or something
no uh that i don't know
remember that's why i mean i know he
paid someone to no there was
just to be naked while he smoked cracks
that's what i know
tim neal yeah i i i i walk in the wild
so famously dark side of
the dark side of hollywood city side
attended the town
uh you know there was like these girls
that he kept filming and everyone
it was the first big star that was
behaving you got the wrong guy to figure
it out for us
but basically his behavior was a little
shocking for his level
there was drama around him he would pay
people to be naked while he smoked crack
i mean that again that's to the
to the to the to the uh i think we might
know that
everything we do uh the level
that's from the rush limbaugh files of
like you know what
awful but [ __ ] hilarious awful but
great if you are inspired if you're
inspired to do that and you can do it
it's so funny it's the britney spears we
all were laughing not one person was
correct
no you guys not cool the aids
changed things and i'm not trying to
link them i just think it's funny that
he actually did have aids while being
promiscuous
and can still in 2021 land
uh like a promo gig yeah foreign
nice health yep like in telehealth
company
sunny it's sunny they're on a high hill
they are
wait you've seen it yeah okay i was like
damn very good the fact that there is an
uh hiv medicine commercial where
only black people but at the end two
black guys make out
and no one said a [ __ ] word
well how about it's only gay people or
black women
that's that i don't the only people in
it there's a
white drag lady great there's a checks
there's a gay there's a gay man in a
inter-racial relationship with a some
sort of
ethnic man i don't know brown man brown
man number one
uh and then it's just either black
gay men or single
black females i cannot that's
interesting i cannot that's
a funny case of who do we cast
why do people get aids where
no i don't i don't they there's a chance
that they thought they were being
progressive okay in their defense like
it's not a huge chance probably a 30
chance in their defense there is
aids does get spread throughout the
black community in a way
it just gets spread throughout different
communities differently in their defense
fine because i looked into i was very
mad uh but
why people get aids of course i don't
know i'm going to watch it again
with this in mind i spot it on tv freeze
it
um yeah that's but that's
about the make out why do you use your
hang up with the makeup d
because do you you're too young to
remember thank you
gay people when there was a gay kiss on
television
it was the number one story
i remember there was gay kiss on i think
mtv
one of their gay uh sex
they were just every i felt like every
weekend in the 90s on mtv there would be
um that like song what's it like
air or something like doo doo doo doo
yeah
that song and uh gay people making out
but that was a big [ __ ] deal the
first time there was like a gay kiss on
camera was like
oh my heavens right so to just see it on
a commercial i'm like [ __ ]
this is such are you oh my heavens i
don't give a [ __ ] no it's a sign of
progress i don't i'm not like actually
like
what about my the children give a [ __ ]
um
it's more i mean at this point they're
saving 60 year olds more than they're
saving children
right they're like oh like right it's
more upsetting to old people than young
people um
but the fact that no one mentions it is
like a sign of progress
well it also it's so funny to me
especially growing up
you do sexual education in a weird way
in elementary school at least
in my [ __ ] go ahead i'm [ __ ]
behind the dumpster
no there's a lot of
the best
like kids at a like a baseball game and
afterwards there's a pizza party it's
like why is timmy not around
he got his blood transfusion it's very
like sterile
and boring but one time we learned about
this kid who got i it was like a life
story of his kids like a lifetime movie
from the 80s ryan white
um i don't know but he got it through
blood transfusion
that was like the famous one okay and
then
um they not all it was just very
ostracizing and the community was like
you ain't gonna exclude my kid oh yeah
that was a huge thing yeah it was so he
had to do
it through this speaker it didn't work
it was really [ __ ] up right but i
always think about that when i think of
corona where i'm like why at what point
do you give a [ __ ] so you don't care
about so we make such a big deal i mean
people made such a big deal about aids
like
it's contagious stay away from these
people like we really ostracize people
when we don't understand something and
if you don't understand a
sickness we go towards like stay away
generally
but with coronavirus everyone is like
breathe on me well if everybody has
freedom
yes it's what myth am i telling myself
which is i believe i'm strong and i
remember
and the aids smith was like i ain't no
homo yeah okay
so i and i don't like consorting with
homos and i don't want my boy console
is consorting with homos neither that's
a really good point because now corona
is like you're a homo
if you wear a mouse if you wear a mask
yeah you bareback it
you get in that you get in that ass um
uh so dalia uh i mean
obviously rest in power king but he had
no he had no choice
it's this great he did the script the
thing about saying he cheated on his
fiancee i thought was like the most
effective part
um and uh
because you go oh yeah it's not that
felt like he actually
felt bad about it the thing where he
said uh you know i kind of thought
any guy would do this in this situation
and he was like they wouldn't yeah they
would i i'm with him on that
five or six three and
handsome and all that [ __ ] like
you know i i i he was a
he was a honest phone a lot like he was
like he had it bad
but uh i think a lot of you saying that
or was he like hinting that he is
sex addicted i
he said i have a problem he didn't say
sex addiction but
i think he the problem i understand sexy
problem was having a sex addiction
is uh the clinical definition of is of
it
is that you uh would
rather have sex than do anything else
to the point that it damages the rest of
your life
comma and you get caught that's the
that's the that's the caveat and you get
caught doing it that's because
the secretary can find if you can do it
the sultan brunei
no problem uh because he can just fly
people in and
yeah that's it i don't know um so uh
the i guess he admitted it i don't
[ __ ] know
he but he it wasn't yeah i'll say it
wasn't clinical i think it will help
i think it will be uh very helpful
yeah um in a way that
maybe louie could have done one maybe
i don't i in a weird way i mean maybe
people just louie did a statement
i think i've always felt like luke
should've in the video i do think
the way i don't know maybe it's helpful
i don't i think it's hard to gauge
because we're our vantage point is
how what do you do in these positions if
you want to address it
openly and you don't want to hide behind
a pr or an
agency or you know someone or just words
on paper so what do you how do you
address it but what do you say it's just
it's so many
you know what i gage is could if i were
going to a crystalia show
could i invite a woman what
to think it through if i were going to a
crystallia show
would i if i had a if i had tickets to
see louie
aziz and dalia on the same night
and which show
would i be most comfortable inviting a
woman obviously
why because he's tiny no no because
his was the one i feel like had the most
disagreement on both sides
wasn't very clear was it a bad date was
he just
weird and has no game was it threat i
don't it
it hurts my head because i think
the truest determination of if it was
good or not
is did he did he make someone feel
really uncomfortable well he did
so i don't know is it fruitful to debate
whether she's in the right or wrong i
don't know you know it just becomes
yeah well that's that begs a whole other
question which is like
um i have a couple questions which
i don't think any of these guys can
actually get
the forgiveness of the people that
are against them um no because it does
feel
a little bit like something done in the
dark so when something dumb done in the
dark comes to light whether it really
was or not
it's hard to you know it's hard to
really truth yeah or it's hard to move
on from that right but i don't i think
that people that are mad
at aziz louie and dalia are not mad at
them per se they're mad at the system
they're mad at
sexism yeah and they're mad at probably
the specific guy who did some [ __ ] like
that to them
and they just put chris and all those
guys with those people so
getting being able to like take
aziz out be like okay i
i trust you now or i trust you
now dalia or i trust louie now
i that's the the the show thing
i'd be curious to see what most people
think i'm i may do a twitter
quiz who's what show would you be most
comfortable bringing a woman to is that
is that a necessary question no not
nothing not no no i know but in the
world of neil is that a necessary
question
i'm curious as to who's got the most
successful rehab
that's what i'm who's bounced but who
did you because to me
watching it i was like ah he'll be
deleted is going to be
something about his because it was a
video by himself and just him
exceptionally talking was like that's
pretty
that's more effective and not polished
the way
louis had to release a statement quickly
within like a half an hour
and that would like had some problem
like the women found problematic
azizus was in his show that was like
guys thought it was too apologetic and
women women weren't
nobody was happy i felt like dalia
today two days later i'm like that to me
might be the most effective one
is there a way to bounce because we're
really talking about entertainment
men something to do with sex
something to do with everybody else
house entertainment man something to do
with sex go ahead
um some form of misconduct allegations
right
he's there in hollywood just because
hollywood is very
and entertainment industry is very
reputation heavy and not even your
actual reputation
what your perceived reputation is and
who you are
perceived to be so is there a way to
resurrect that is it even
it's such a there's such a high turn
like is it even worth trying
because you're always going to have
that's the question is
i'm talking to somebody about the
doubling down thing
it's if you double down
and say i did nothing wrong and
i completely disagree with these women i
think they're doing it you can literally
go like i think they're doing it for
whatever attention any of that [ __ ]
you automatically lose women right
automatically
is it worth
in the long term are you better off are
you not this tour but the tour after
that
if you're one of the if you get accused
of something if you're like
an outlaw you know like
chris brown um chris brown's
i don't know why it's just different not
like to me yeah but
just [ __ ] gets a different shake down
sometimes what about though
louis still tours do you think
comedians he tours in smaller venues
though
and if he'd been an outlaw about it
you know what he has to do he just
doesn't make that he has to make the
tickets so expensive he's like you
better really want to see me well no
that's not the issue the issue is
it's who comes to your show who's going
to tell people they're going to it's a
it's a it's a bit of a trump thing where
it's yeah it's dirty
it's like one time somebody i think but
it's way more emotional
it's way more visceral than like i have
further looked inside my
you know yeah no it's true it's funny
one time um what's his face
somebody who's on stage um rick and
was trying to out trump supporters it's
like who's trump's affording you
and i was standing next to the table
they're like don't say anything yeah and
i
i always remember that yeah because i
had the
urge to point it
is secretive half the people you see are
trump support i mean not in l.a but
like they're all tourists at the store a
lot of the maturity so let's just
a lot more than will raise their hand
you know yeah but it is
it's the same thing who's gonna say oh i
have two tickets to
and that's the thing i'm saying and then
try inviting a girl
when you can get it because i think even
girls at a point would be like
i like this outlaw a lot of these girls
are foolish you know like then you
tap into their misogyny well the funny
okay example i invited a friend to this
he was like i want to come to store i
want to bring my friends i was like cool
so i saved them a seat
and it was a regular like one just the
store
lineup so it's a [ __ ] assorted box of
chocolates i mean this isn't one-person
show no and i mean it's
a lot of times it was my show at the end
of the night
although i did a joke the other night
that i'd like defend dalia
but as soon as he gets a spot earlier
today i'm going to be like let's not
forget about what he did
is that how you bring him up yeah look
i'll bring this
yeah um so uh
he brought him and a girl and a guy
friend of his
and the girl was like
there was somebody on that i won't
mention but someone that's a polarizing
uh figure she's like i run a blog
like i can't be seen watching this guy's
show
like it first first of all a million
things we're not even gonna dress like
yeah
no one cares about it yeah but she even
she was just like nah
i associate way too many things it's
against that person that if someone knew
that i went
and sat through and even gave this guy a
chance
it's not good for my bottom line so i do
but that's a lot of
how people watch it now am i allowed to
like this
am i allowed to laugh at this i can hear
it in ju like
jokes like
like that
[Music]
because they're like i think it's funny
i'm you can hear the conflict in people
but that's where you can't even
uh everyone's
it's this everyone's in the they are the
show
they're at the show it's like the social
media vacation of [ __ ]
the ta but if you if you double down
made yourself an outlaw like the the
comic they don't want you to see all
that [ __ ]
and then you tap into women who are like
i think a lot of these girls are kind of
right and then they come and then they
get we're we we love you we don't care
what anybody says
well it's like you could i [ __ ] hate
kim kardashian but if she was in line
next you'd be like oh my god hey girl
yeah everyone is just i don't know
everyone is kind of full of [ __ ]
yeah so let's not expose my full of
shitness by going to your shell
yeah i think the yes
i always said it was people
could take kanye's sum up
kanye's political [ __ ] but once he
started throwing jesus it was like i
can't this is boring
um malcolm x who was he malcolm x
it's his it's he was murdered 55 years
ago
56 why this year is he getting more uh
because in undercover nypd
detective on his deathbed released uh
mate wrote a letter and was like that's
the way to die
to my earlier well who's going to be in
your in your
uh who am i going to drop you i'm on oh
you'll see what's your deathbed
confession
i'm going to edit it i'm going to be
like let's take this out
um we don't need neil tries to do a
cover or
wrote a letter in which he admitted he
participated in actions that in
hindsight were deplorable and
detrimental to the advancement of my own
black people
oh so he was basically he was keith
stanfield
and uh in the black messiah so he had to
infiltrate uh civil rights groups in new
york
and um if he heard they were gonna they
were gonna
like put a bomb at the central liberty
okay so basically let's um
get all of it it's like a rico case it's
like let's get
all of the people around him caught up
so they can't protect so it's a lot of
his
security bodyguards and entrusted
group of his inner circle so let's go
either coax them into committing a crime
that they will then get caught for or
hey i know about a crime
foil the plan so they're all caught up
so that he doesn't have
the actual security he should to allow
somebody armed
to kill him so that is just it's like it
was uh it wasn't like it was
okay so it was like a downstream thing
it's like freezing assets
it's just like all right well then let's
see how you wiggle out of this one
yeah that's the thing about terrorist
groups is or any so-called terrorist
groups as most of the time it's
the fbi we've talked about it before
that with al qaeda and isis they would
most of the guys that got busted after 9
11 fbi would
join a mosque an fbi guy and here we go
you want to do terrorism they're going
to be like no
yeah are you sure come on let's do
terrorism i think i'd be like no
come on and then finally gotta be like
uh all right i'll have lunch
just make it just [ __ ] get this over
with and then like you mother you
blocking piece of [ __ ]
um then they drop the they open the the
van door and it's over um
yeah i don't i you know what i've i've
been thinking
based on i alm
based on uh uh a bunch of [ __ ] but kind
of based on the um
adam curtis documentary was
whenever black people say something was
bad it was worse than that
do you know what i mean like whenever
they go it was really civil rights was
really hard and then you see it you're
like that's worse than hard
and with i want to say i don't want to
say why
but the white version is war war is so
bad that white people
old white men won't even talk about it
right like that's when you know it's bad
black people have been in war for
hundreds of years no right but i'm
saying but they don't
a lot of black guys don't talk about it
either what i'm saying is yeah
civil rights [ __ ] it's always worse
like and the way they infiltrated the
black panthers and all that other shows
right no it's it's
even i mean it's funny because i heard
this before
rock said it but i know a few friends
that are older black men
that could only go to a
like a farmhouse vet for their dentistry
you know
that was normal so to hear it once it's
shocking but
when you realize that was a norm that
wasn't a weird thing to people
and i think we just gloss over it
because it's
too sad and also sounds made up
it's
even the tooth the the vet thing they
didn't think was real
no people don't think that was real but
even i was
i was talking to somebody who is like
contrarian for contrarian's sake
i was sort of kind of defending not
trump but whatever something
not that i believe in and i told him
like my friend just moved into a house
in mid-city
and the and the covenants it said
nobody can re own this property that
that isn't white no
like really there's racist covenants
that we ignore
they don't even take it out we still
have to pass a law to take them out
we just actively agree to ignore it and
it's such a
analogy to racism it's like no
should we pass a law so that like a
lovely black couple doesn't have to see
that they probably weren't allowed to be
here 20 uh
50 100 years ago just ignore it like
it's fine just
don't read it and people don't think
that's small that's not even
that's a very passive form of racism
like please don't be black
okay fine here um and
people don't believe that's actually a
thing so i you know
is it is it like is it important to
convince white people still i don't know
we kind of do but we kind of still try
but not really
um yeah
it is just because there's so many ways
so keep trying
13 black people i mean 14 15 it's just
not
enough people to to
wait it out you know what i mean
yeah i was watching a stacey that's you
know what made me think of stacey abrams
there's a stacey avengers documentary on
um
amazon oh yeah yeah is it good yeah it
really is actually
um i'm only like halfway through but
whenever i get a little factoid it's
like [ __ ]
uh after after
world war ii
no that's not right anyway the amount of
because of the poll taxes and just black
people getting [ __ ] murdered voting
and all that [ __ ] the black registration
rate
for voting in i believe 1960
was three percent
effective i mean yeah they go i don't
even want
them to have my name right like yeah
you're not going to get
many black candidates at one point it
would have been 65
wow and then it was after reconstruction
i believe it was 65
and then or during reconstruction and
then and then they
yeah three percent which is just [ __ ]
insane
uh black southerness in the post civil
rights
era dion sanders speaking of
this is a very black shirt it's about to
get blacker roll the window roll the
windows up everybody it's about to get
blacker
um dion sanders is a coach
in uh
he was he coaches a black college
coaches jackson state right cool
he's the head coach uh and they were
doing
a he was at a game
and [ __ ] got stolen
out of the locker room it was was it at
jackson state
um
yeah edward waters so edward waters is
another school so
so they're doing it they're doing a game
and uh they're doing a game they're
performing a game
and uh during the game somebody broke
into the jackson state locker room
and took dion sanders stuff
it's since been returned i'd like to
think that they were
heavily threatened um
stephen a smith basically implied
that's the yelling guy yeah it's black
people's dirty laundry
and kind of don't show it in front of
white people
he didn't say that first of all people
steal what does this have to do with
black people
it's a black college uh it's a pr it's a
hbcu i believe
and stephen a smith was saying
by promoting that or even
uh bringing that to light you're making
it harder to recruit
students in the future it's basically
just like don't
no it's a he's saying like keep it
between us
it's like dog he got robbed well that's
the that's the black you think that it
would be harder to
recruit like i don't understand i think
it's gonna be hard
anyway and i think uh
a parent that wants to send their kid to
an hbcu
that wants to go to an hbcu who's good
enough to get recruited by multiple
colleges
i don't i don't i think i think it's
kind of worth
whatever [ __ ] goes along with hbcu in
this case it's a
robber during a game it happened in the
[ __ ] at the
philadelphia 76ers the co the owner's
brother stole from iverson's so it
happens
it just happens i don't think it's um no
i don't think it's especially
but why do you think steve no of course
not but why stephen
avery stephen a smith oh steven steven
avery is the drummer from jane's
addiction
but close sorry
why is that why stephen uh
making it almost feels worse to make to
connect the dots in that direction
than if we just let it be weird he has a
lot of weird angles that's a weird a
that's a very weird angle i mean there
is something to
airing dirty laundry i believe i don't
know what the line is but there are
times where
sure no where it's like do we need to
make
a big deal about this but sorry thief
thief is thief
thief yeah it's not like that's a
accepted
thing like well we steal here it's still
a crime it's not like well it's legal
it's during the game it's legal right um
yeah like it's it's uh here steven a
smith's quote is the reason i would have
handled it differently is because the
actions of a few
a criminal act the unfortunate actions
the embarrassing actions
should not be a reflection on jackson
state
that is how it may be inhaled and
grasped and interpreted by those on the
outside white people
yeah of course uh hbcus have incredible
challenges that have highlighted on many
many
occasions you see how stephen smith
stephen a smith
uh he just repeats the same [ __ ] over
and over again
uh in terms of notoriety cache intro
here comes the
synonyms in terms of notoriety cache
interest support
financial uh and otherwise it is a
challenge for historically black
colleges university to receive those
things
this does not help
buddy it's not with the guy talking
about
getting robbed it's a college someone
went into a [ __ ] locker room and took
some [ __ ]
is that's happened one million times not
at harvard
right but i'm just saying i don't know i
feel like
almost the worst offenders stephen
avery smith we don't know what the a
stands for
um to connect those dots or just
i don't know why are you trying to why
are we no no
don't look whites don't you don't see
anything here
oh it's a it's a it's an
old it's an old man oh it's anthony
yeah he'll always be avery to me um it's
an old it's an old
it might be an old black person's
mentality like over a certain age you're
like ah
i get it but i get i don't know how many
people are
i don't know i i it's also thinking that
i don't agree with that white people are
and
will white people use it as ammunition
for racism yeah
probably but they're you can't
anyone who's looking for ammunition
they'll just [ __ ]
macgyver some [ __ ] together yeah into
into a a uh weapon
to use against so you know what thieves
of jackson state
do what you do playboy no keep stealing
playboy
that's what i took from that's what i
took from it and that
that is what stealing is to me
um oh meek mill
do you see what he wrote what do you say
yeah now
in for taste meek mill in
poor taste um
now here's the funny thing i don't even
think it's the story of tyler the
creator says it
how i he's not like a troll
if eminem it's not good
he would do lyrics like he would do like
trolling lyrics okay
it's like makes not really a troller no
uh and um
that's more than anything uh
what this is like what are you well like
you're not like a [ __ ] troll person
why are you do and you probably knew
kobe it's not up
we're talking technically uh there are
rhymes to be made about kobe
i just wouldn't involve a helicopter
just if you're
if you're out there young rappers
don't involve a helicopter but you know
eventually
magic and aids became a thing to wrap up
like it all gets there
just give it time rotten rhymes just
give it time my son
um yeah it just seems
like you probably knew
that when you were writing you probably
knew
ooh someone might not like that you know
yes you know
of course there are but there are jokes
that you know
are on the line that i sometimes i can't
believe they work
um so this is
what is it yeah and if
and if i ever lack i'm going out with my
chopper
it'll be another kobe bryant kobe sorry
so
if he's saying yeah and if i ever lack
i'm going out with my chopper
it'll be another kobe so i don't know
people are gonna die i mean i don't it's
not it's all pretty clear
everybody was it's not uh it's a
it's fine they got to write a lot of
rhymes these guys rats and rhymes
well also there's so many [ __ ] up
rhymes yeah
well that's the thing it's like it's
like that's the sanctimony around like
what go back to sorry uh loosely raping
women
what happened to that those are the
lyrics i wanted those are the kinds of
lyrics i can get behind
loosely raping it ain't no fun if the
homies can't have none or
b.i.g bring that ass to me i mean come
on that was a whole other
that was a whole other issue i i'm sorry
guys i shouldn't have done that duncan
needed to see the rhymes up close
she needed to inspect the rhyme the
rhyme inspector we
took our she needs a read and we also
get to see
the fact that bianca needs classes and
will not admit it
she does the old lady thing where she
holds it up
so you know that's hip-hop for you
okay sometimes you're going to get some
errant rhymes
sometimes you feel like a nut sometimes
you don't um
but do you think the meek mill i've
always considered the black ari shafir
so it only makes sense that he finally
came
for kobe he'll be fine yeah he'll be
fine okay
i also think he like has uh migmal's a
lot of like side deals now
that are barely music related like he's
like a puma space
yeah he got he had the weirdest come up
after jail was like
jay-z just organized all this [ __ ] for
him yeah it sounds
he feels like jay-z-ish thinks he's i
don't i
well he's it's the same management
company and it's
all that [ __ ] i don't he's never going
to get to j level but i for some reason
he got
a ton of goodwill even though he was
imprisoned uh
illegally um it's not based on
music well i mean it was like it was
it was just stupid specious legal
theories right right or wagging his
finger
um my queen serena moving on
lost serene queen serene queen of serena
uh lost in australia and uh people think
she's gonna retire or something
she's ranked ten she ain't retiring she
did uh
the way she they analyzed the way she
put her hand
the goodbye they don't know well i don't
think i
i don't think she's gonna retire she you
she makes
she's much more
uh profitable playing even if she's not
winning
oh yeah i feel like she's like i'm gonna
go out on top
or like it's gonna take
she can suck for three years tennis
the tennis uh like that she can play for
three more years and the tennis is such
a poorly understood uh thing
that most people won't even know she
sucks for a while
like it'll just take a a while before
people go like
oh like i didn't no by the way like no
tennis players careers have lasted this
long
at this level like martina navratilova
what about the
federer federer i guess so i remember
saying serena like
you weren't supposed to be good this
long right she's been good for
20 years like that's [ __ ] hard to do
i remember their
got milk commercial their got milk ads
like this back when people used to drink
cow's milk that's how long that was
the yeah i don't i she's not retired i
hope she doesn't
she's not she just won't like it there's
no way but that you know i started
after um
they're just so obsessed with her like
the way she's
um shown in the media and like it's
tennis but she
supersedes tennis in a way i started
looking back at it and
they're so unfair to serena rhymes they
like she gets such an unfair shakedown
it's it goes past
it's like britney spears level it's like
that britney spears dog it
i remember i read something that when
she was pregnant they made a case that
she
her metabolism is unfair testosterone
and her blood from
ra having a baby it's just something
she's pregnant yeah and because she's
doing so good
well she's pregnant so her metabolism
and its house it's actually doubles
she's playing there's two of her
and i'm like generally we give pregnant
people like it's considered
harder to be pregnant to do things but
sometimes
there's a combination with serena where
she's a bit
of an outlaw she doesn't [ __ ] with the
she don't [ __ ] with
it's like they didn't they don't [ __ ]
with each other yeah but they write all
the articles
so it seems i just no one talks about
how
unfair of a shakedown she gets yeah
absolutely she got
she yelled at a judge whatever two years
ago and said they were a thief and all
that stuff
but mcenroe it's like yeah he's wild
yeah it's it's just what stories do
white people want to tell themselves
one of the stories they love telling
themselves and i know because i tell it
to myself
every night as i go to sleep is uh
is we're not racist right not real
what i call him like i see him
what's that a a a dominant black woman
what i wouldn't make comments about her
body that i would
that i wouldn't make about white women
it's like you can't
it's just ra it's just racist but it's
so
it's so embarrassing that they just have
to go like
well it's all this other like this it's
a huh
the idea of you falling asleep and
telling yourself a giant book i'm not a
giant book called white mets i'm not
racist
um white i'm a good bad boy
except for the except absolutely hello
um anyhow brings us to doc watch
um yeah so i saw alan versus pharaoh
i haven't watched it i want to watch it
i was like
this is kind of funny this is what
this is what was doing okay yeah i don't
like talking about masturbation
come on but last night it was around it
was around closing i was it was i
i know i had to read my white myths to
myself and uh
and so i either had i was either gonna
watch
the woody allen documentary or
masturbate and i was like if i watch it
i can't mess i'm not gonna be able to
masturbate
why can't you uh you don't wanna watch
about child molestation
oh okay and then segway in a light
segway i think that brings us to because
you can't do asian
there's so many categories that are
massive in the bed i don't need to get
into any of this
i know you wouldn't tell me this is i
think you're you're a rude person
um yeah you can't it ruins it for the
you're like
you have to become like a moral outrage
yeah so i just kept it hidden
um it was
it's so dense and they really fine tooth
comb
because as a kid you always heard you
know william woody allen
married his whatever daughter
um but
no one seemed to make a big deal about
it eventually
at least once
having never been into older uh younger
women even when i was young i was always
like if i was when i was like 18 i was
like trying to [ __ ]
late 20s women um
i need a certain amount of sag you know
what i mean that's changed a little
hanging um now i flipped it
did i tell you i flipped it um no but so
i've just never been into younger women
so but apparently
in the 70s it was like a thing and like
led
zeppelin would [ __ ] 13 year olds and
they were fine with it and their parents
were fine with
that one song she's
just
they say yes it is she's just 16 years
old leave her alone they say
but crazy right they say it's a it's an
outlaw song it's like they don't
understand our love jerry lee lewis
[ __ ]
their meredith they played that song yes
there are a ton uh who is it
by benny mardonas
he played a lot give us some underage
lyrics just type it in well
underage girl
[Music]
um 18 creepy songs about younger women
that you've been
singing along to without realizing it
itsy bitsy titsy girl i kind of had a
feeling
okay uh christine 16 was a kiss
how dare you oh never gonna give it up
get it okay i always get it up for the
younger kind
for the touch of the younger kind good
morning little school girl
girl you'll be a woman soon yeah
we didn't mind it no one i don't
remember people picketing uh
uh uh [ __ ] uh pulp fiction
straight cat blues by the rolling stones
rolling stones have like a black lady
some brown sugars about [ __ ] black
women
uh they put it in the title young girl
yeah
i to march by vehicle i mean yeah it's
don't stand no
that's about him young teacher the
subject
of school girl fantasies it's like uh
this girl is half
his age clack clack
um my ayahuasca brother
oh just brown sugar just like a young
girl should yeah
yeah so like again i'm not saying
i'm saying it as like that used to be
like a
thing like a status thing
um there was a woman today in the paper
who said that woody allen
i guess [ __ ] her when she was 16 and
he was 38 40.
um that's again i
they're almost two different things to
me but the the difference is that
you realize that um he was very
you know children of earth like didn't
want him it'll keep him away from ronan
whose party i took you to right his
birth name was satchel
yeah i know yeah which is uh
that was weird i was like now if you
want a counter argument to all this
because the my problem with the woody
allen stuff is
whatever i read or see i believe
whatever the last thing i read or
believed
i believe so moses pharaoh
yeah wrote a blog
two years ago three years ago that
you'll read it and go
i believe this and it's not exonerates
woody allen
mia pharaoh is a crazy person but you
know what's funny and you see in the
documentary and so it's four parts
they only have one part out is that he
took a liking to
moses and treat and moses was the only
one of her kids that didn't have a dad
and he was so like drawn to him and what
from what i can see
from what i know in the first um part
is that woody allen really did a divide
and conquer
like he was obsessed over
moses and then when mia faro said
something like you know i'd like to be
pregnant again i'd like to have them
kids
he was not really into it but he said
well if you adopt
he's like i could i'm more partial to it
if you
adopt a blonde kid that looked a little
bit more like us
then i'd be more into it so then she
adopted dylan
and so dylan and moses he was really
obsessed with moses until
dylan came around and the way everyone
describes how
obsessed and she would say you know i
was like his kid
and he would tell me oh mommy doesn't
want you around mommy is
too busy for you dylan's the red-haired
woman now right
okay mom and she said she felt like i
was his and i
had to be with him and when he came in
the room her demeanor would change so i
do
wonder if that's true and that seems to
be actually pretty true with all
so many people so many people's accounts
of the situation including dylan
i do wonder who's more impartial to what
you know it also seems like he wasn't a
big fan of the point
so i'm like well the ronin thing i
remember reading that at some point he
just said like
me and this kid don't get along yeah
like did they mention the frank sinatra
element that hasn't come up do you know
what that is
absolutely not what's going on well look
up
just google ronan pharaoh well
maybe he's frank sinatra's kid and not
woody allen's kid
well they were trying to have a kid and
it wasn't working that's what like
there's so this is a roshaman
thing at this point where everyone's
saying something different
and it's like he kind of looks more like
frank sinatra
yeah yeah yeah he's so handsome like
it's the best looking why don't they
just do a dna test
i don't know i don't know i mean he
looks
like i'm saying is i don't i just pranks
and i'll just because i know
i know ronan oh my god i know i'm taking
you to his home
oh my god his mug shot and ronin looked
the ignorance now
ronan looks so much like mia farrow not
when you
put this up no i mean they side by side
they're like
identical like that's hey ronan is that
you and mimo that's me
pharah um so um
she's an olive in the dark which i like
yeah it's very like
horse's mouth i know yes but
it's not all of the horses well no in in
the documentary's defense
um i haven't seen
yeah um so there's no way to spoil it
it's so dense it's so dense but
in the documentary's defense
um woody allen i guess
in 2020 recorded tapes and put them out
called like he made it he wrote a book
he wrote a book
yeah yeah so it's on he also recorded on
tape so they have
that i'm assuming he didn't agree to the
documentary but they have had
that as a counter to a lot of the things
they say and he says like i was like
took a strong liking to moses of all the
kids so he was like the closest with him
at first you know when he started
hanging around and he thought
oh you know i don't want anything to do
with the kids they live separately but
then he found himself
filling the role and actually being
there for them and blah blah blah and
like
so it's not that his voice isn't heard
but no i don't i mean he released a
statement today calling and said it was
a hatchet job like
i'm sure yeah that's
i just think it's like i don't i don't
think we'll ever know
that's how i feel i don't know watch the
first part read
let me just read you a section go back
to moses
moses thing the fatal dysfunction within
my childhood
had nothing to do with woody it began
long before he entered the picture and
came straight from a deep and persistent
darkness
within the pharaoh family it was common
knowledge in hollywood that my
grandfather the director john farrow
was a notorious drinker and a serial
philanderer there were
numerous alcohol-fueled arguments
between her parents
and mia told me that she was the victim
of attempted molestation within her own
family
her brother my uncle john who visited us
many times when we were young
is currently in prison on a conviction
of multiple child molestation charges
so that's me and pharah's brother my
mother has never publicly commented on
this or expressed concern about his
victims
uh my uncle patrick and his family would
often come by and those visits
could end abruptly as me and patrick
would often end up arguing
patrick would commit suicide in 2009. my
mother of course had her own darkness
she married a 50 year old frank sinatra
when she was only 21.
um frank sinatra wrote a song about her
called she's so
young what did this young piece of tale
uh after they divorced she moved uh in
to live with her close friend
uh dory piven and her husband andre when
my mother became pregnant by
by andre the prevalence marriage broke
up leading to dory's
institutionalization
it's never spoken of in our home of
course and not even known to me until a
few years ago but as i look at it as a
licensed therapist
and as an eyewitness it's easy to see
the seeds of dysfunction that would
flourish within our home
there's more [ __ ] about her locking them
in closets and just like
i that's why i'm saying like i don't i
think woody allen's a [ __ ]
psycho make no mistake uh
i just don't think it can be known
i just the only thing for me is like so
let's just assume
there was just massive dysfunction
everyone you can't pinpoint it
they weren't this like blissful family
and
also reading that it does gloss i mean i
don't know we haven't seen all four
parts but right now it looks
like a lovely picturesque family a
family an idyllic family
ruined by woody allen right but the
problem is
that uh so tsuyun gets this the ending
is literally the end of part one is like
they discover the photos
and they she addresses it with the
family and tries is like
daddy took naked pictures of suian and
dylan's like
oh i'm not the only one
that's the end so it's like yeah there's
dysfunction
everywhere yeah and like it does seem
tumultuous and it does seem like
adoption babies whatever
also why would you there were signs
there was so much
of her knowing woody allen had
inappropriate
behavior people calling it out in her
building saying i
there's some [ __ ] going on with him and
then taking him to therapist
hey you need to work so you're you know
that there's something going on so
already like i'm with her until
he's doing inappropriate touching and
you take him to a therapist to work
through it
as opposed to get the [ __ ] away from my
children
you've got to lose your job so it's like
okay well i wouldn't i would never
entertain a relationship where my the
my boyfriend and my adopted daughter
that he said i'd be more fond of
and treat her like my own if she looked
like she was white and not a bunch of
yeah
like and you're in a bed in their
underwear and everyone is like
the little girl's grabbing and his penis
in public like
and you want to work through that so
something has to be up with you
do you know what i mean with mia with
mia yeah who i mean
that's the thing is i don't the other
the next one
um uh it was important to my mother to
project to the world a picture of happy
blended household
of both biological and adopted children
but this was far from the truth
sure my mother had good intentions in
adopting children with disabilities from
the
from the direst of circumstances but the
reality
inside our walls was very different it
pains me to recall instances in which
i witness siblings some blind or
physically disabled
drag down a flight of stairs to be
thrown into a bedroom or a closet
than having the door locked from the
outside she even shut my brother
thaddeus paraplegic from polio in an
outdoor shed overnight as punishment for
a minor digression
tran i'm sorry transgression yeah so
this is another
one of the kids that another horse
that's the th you know
and that's why i
uh pray it's never left
thank you that's my guy
so you know what i'm saying is that
i don't believe just from that because
they don't talk a lot about it and who
knows maybe it's like you know who knows
what the strategy is to tell the story
the first part is oh picture us and then
we go into what the kid
i mean and the reviews have been like
this is damning conclusive evidence
against woody allen
it is and that's what i just wish they
would link to this the thing is
this doesn't exonerate woody allen
because i mean no
i agree i i think like i said i think
woody allen's a [ __ ] psycho i think
he's an amazing
uh comedian joke writer and and one of
the greatest filmmakers sucks too
because they go through all his movies
like
and i'm just like [ __ ] i love that oh
that's a bad i love that one too but
um what it shows is that
there was a talk there was a grounds for
toxicity
that the wrong person was allowed to
flourish in
i mean it's gross and enough
outside people like some world-renowned
uh psychologist world-renowned was lives
in
part of the documentary no no i like
looked it up she's like written about
she's just lived in this rich people
building in new york so it's not like
wild um and then she rang her and was
like
i saw woody like she on her own was like
i saw him
greet your daughter something's wrong
there the the
intensity he greeted her with like a
[ __ ]
peeping talk of of sunni or no no
nothing about sunni
except the photos that you don't hear
her talk really about hear both of them
talk about sunni
um this therapist just saw him in the
lobby
greet dylan and she was so concerned
she was like that was [ __ ] weird
yeah so if there's enough in there's
enough evidence on both sides that like
look uh awesome the more these my
genius peers fall off the better i look
they're not your peers look my genius
woody allen is my filmmaking pier
i would put half baked in the goods up
against annie hall in manhattan
any day of the week and lose
in a blowout um there's a documentary on
hbo
max plus purple
purple drink hbo um
salmon x uh same kind of pantone
um called black it's basically just
black art
i saw that it's dope it's great it's
just a very
roll call of like
carrie james marshall and and carol
walker
retailer uh i don't remember that
okay uh what maybe um
is he alive yeah yeah he's in l.a he's
one of my favorite artists
but what's what henry taylor is his name
yeah henry taylor
they're just that looks like carrick
james marshall i mean it's the it it
uh yeah but it's funny the person who
care james marshall kind of bit of style
from a professor there's a couple things
in it that are just great
one of the professors uh
did a who taught
carrie james marshall said they would do
an
exercise where they would do a collage
right
and but and it was this i guess they
would cut out the different pieces ahead
of time
and you had to make a collage with the
same pieces four different ways
in subsequent weeks which just hearing
that is like [ __ ] that's such a good way
to
approach anything like you have to do it
for take four different approaches so
you didn't get
to like like this is my baby that one
it's you just like right maybe like
let's try it that way
right um and also the carriage james
marshall
kind of bit his kind of style from
the teacher um and
uh rock told me a [ __ ] hilarious
eddie murphy thing that if you said
something funny around eddie in the 80s
that he could use in his act he'd be
like
you better turn that over to proper
authority
which is so [ __ ] funny i don't think
he actually would take it he was just it
was just kind of [ __ ] on people
uh but watch black art it's great um
well let's do some emails huh honey
[Music]
and bb l-s-t-n-e-r
ding that's nice oh neil
whip it every time you say the former
ceo of amazon's name
you pronounce it bezos and every other
time i've heard it
it's pronounced bezos yeah do you know
something we don't know
is this winner's circle intel or do you
just say it weird
please tell me i'm on the edge of my
seat it's been bugging me for months
thanks i the truth is i don't know how
to pronounce it
but the other truth is i do
have a winner's circle connection
to jeff bezos that's all that i don't
know
i don't but i don't know how to say it
um what is it
what's his name m-m-a-b mba
no why it's somebody you wouldn't think
interesting
vacations with him sometimes interesting
is he fun small circle
jeff bezos uh i think he
i yeah i just think those guys that this
is
what i said about conspiracy theories is
like those guys are just
busy yeah they don't they're not evil
they're just intense they just want to
do this thing
right they their thing is like he
he wanted to like make a store that had
everything in it's not
like an evil thing he just [ __ ]
had thought he could underwrite
bookstores
and then he was like well maybe we could
do with everything it's like not
like and now i shall i don't think he's
a good guy
but mckenzie sure is hellas yeah
she's a girl she's a good guy she's a
good guy
um all right good one thank you goodbye
you've got me hey neil and bianca long
time feeler here
i have a quick question i was recently
married
and me and my wife both owned a home
before we got married so now
we have two properties to our names
her house was a little bit nicer so we
decided that we would rent out my house
until we decide what we're going to do
with it
we hired a property manager to look
after the property for us
and recently the property manager called
me and was giving me an update on the
property
and he kept calling me buddy on the
phone
i didn't think anything of it but my
wife overheard this
and said that he was being really
disrespectful
she said that he should call me mr
reynolds and not refer to me
as buddy this guy is a 40-something
american of european ancestry
i'm a late 30-something
american of african ancestry
and i didn't know if he was being
disrespectful or maybe this was
i wanted to see how you guys felt about
it how neil feel
and what binky thinking should i check
this guy until i'm not to call me buddy
and instead call me mr reynolds
or should i just let it go because he
probably wasn't being disrespectful
well let's assume he does assume he
knows he's black
uh
how good do you need to be how clicked
in
do you need to be with your property
manager if it's
like a hierarchy thing you know you can
lay down the law but if you
kind of need him have your back do you
put the guy in his place that you
[Music]
have you put in position to watch your
whole property i don't know
what if you all of a sudden if anyone
has watched my commercials sometimes
white people call black people buddy
and they don't mean anything oh my god
so neil
this is this guy is a plant he works for
kevin hart
uh the i i think there it
is tone i don't know i it's a total tone
issue to me
maybe say yeah i'm not sure but i don't
know it just seems
or couldn't you be like you know what
call me
john or if coleman i don't yeah it also
could be one of those things where the
wife
is being sensitive in a way that
maybe the wife's white and she's sense
i don't i need more information the
thing is you can't be like you know what
call me
blank and if it's something more proper
it's way more aggressive
call me mr mr tip i mean i don't know
what the [ __ ]
what i don't know tommy king yeah call
me mr ander whatever the [ __ ]
reynolds reynolds yeah um
uh i i think you leave it
i i would leave it and if he
presses if he ca if it gets more
collegial from there
if he calls you my guy then you go
that's neil's line he hates my guy
hey you'll hate no boy my guy is the
lion
you hate don't call me my guy it's never
you know never means
it's never meant well from white white
black or black white
in either directions nobody means well
um
how about my guy is the true buddy
buddy can mean something good my guy has
never
i it might have meant something good for
like a week and it was instantly bad it
was just
like all right you [ __ ] crazy person
over there
but i mean i guess it's like oh my god
works at whatever but if you go hey my
guy it's never good
i don't like it and i will and i built a
podcast around
being against it goodbye you've got it
bianca's got an apology to make okay
hi neil and bianca i'm listening to the
podcast now
to clarify the girl on the bachelor did
not wear black face okay it was a
sorority
party where they dressed up like gone
with the wind on a plantation
yes i understand not a great look but
definitely not blackface
thanks the police
uh that police officer leslie so
you so we clarified do you want to
apologize oh yeah my bad i didn't
actually know i just i think we talked
about before
it was the it's the fog of cancellation
i think it was a blackface or i don't
remember it i round it up to because
he wasn't against somebody it just i
don't know he did something wrong
i'm sorry and no one benefits but she's
in trouble
okay so sorority party where they dress
lily gone in the wind plantation
go do you think that's how bad how about
are we talking i think that's bad
now i have thought about remember
like a month ago when i said that
there's something about being
in a foreign country being in like
thailand and like
oh yeah yes there's something tote
that's colony i'm saying i'm making
colonialism
uh sexy cool you like it
you like that the orange
i'll admit it yes that was me
acknowledging
some level of uh enjoying
the spoils
now but yeah i but
whenever i've been anywhere playing
that's the thing about the south that
creeps me out is like you can feel the
[ __ ]
you can feel like the i don't
i don't know like even if you hadn't
if i feel like if i was pl if i woke if
i like was poison and woke up
in a field in the south i would know
that i was in the south more than if i
was somewhere else yeah loud
i hadn't met anyone loud cricket noises
cicadas
and weeping willa i mean yeah everything
i would think yeah
the more obviously the humidity but i
don't there's something about it that's
it's listen plantations are spooky i
don't understand and look they're
obviously gorgeous there were meant to
be gorgeous big houses with these
huge fields well they deserve them okay
but i feel like the south is
the white south are the white
southerners are
really over it they're like it's fine
people died here and were oppressed and
had terrible lives and other kids were
from them and were raped and murdered
but it's like just it's beautiful you
know what they could use is some
catholic guilt and shame
for real and there are a lot of it's a
weird it's it's a weird thing where it
skip them but like skip them but they're
really really shame like
went to philly and boston for some
reason like okay
we'll take it but like we're like the
least
but i don't know why you didn't go for
them why the [ __ ] we
all we did was come here and they
[ __ ]
were like well get yourself a jeweler um
the south still got something to say
hello
lstner this is somewhat of a response to
a letter advising neil to start dating
more black women first i think it's
important to consider if black women are
really out here
actively looking to date guys like neil
let alone kneel himself
i get it i i hate it and i i get it
uh for the black woman who are out here
pining for neil's love and affection
uh they might have to come to terms the
fact that he might not just be all that
into them
i'm a listener from the champs era and
neil has mentioned his lady preferences
many times over the years
black women are very rarely placed on
that list and
all caps that is okay as a black lady
myself i once upon a time became very
distraught after louis ck boldly
proclaimed
that he did not find black women
attractive then we all found out that
his mother that this [ __ ] was
jerking off in front of [ __ ] without
their consent
and i took solace in the fact that
because of his personal preferences a
few potentially susceptible black women
may have been spared um
this is not to say that neil's
performing any sort of sexual misconduct
out here in the streets
i just think that people's sexual
preferences should be left at
just that free from any further scrutiny
particularly because you never know
what's happening behind closed doors you
sure don't
love the show you guys really have you
guys really don't have to take this [ __ ]
it's kind of the nicest thing you said
to us thank you thank you corey
uh oh this is
a side note and uh did you see the meg
in the stallion cover
of the lore my ex
the mixed x was the style it's the
editor
so well that's the thing you've dated
black of course i don't know what she's
talking about
um like one of my longest relationships
um but letterhead
yeah letterhead for [ __ ] sake um for
[ __ ] sake what do you want
you got a black woman letterhead i
didn't like that i didn't like this
that's that's it that's like why is it
so
overly sexual i understand i don't do
you think it's sexual i thought it was
like more like
not sexual well it wasn't sexual but it
it seems um
uh like you took the first idea in the
brainstorming
but i think the way they just didn't
they didn't make it like
it's it's like her at home yeah
unremarkable it looks like a dove ad or
something
you know what i mean yeah when the
ladies like the regular adorned
i think that's was the premise um i know
but
what do women think of that's what i
wonder is like as a guy
honestly
there's a world in which this is sexier
than
uh for sure full makeup i think for men
every guy always says no guy is like i
want you to have a full
face of makeup please they may be
attracted to women like that but they
always
want naturals just [ __ ] gets on
everything
gets on your sheets and [ __ ] it just
gets everywhere it's funny really
if you [ __ ] hard yeah damn neil [ __ ]
hard
okay i [ __ ] the foundation off of it
you know me
through these dishes um so yes but this
is
high fashion [ __ ] so it's not about guys
at all you don't
count here right i guess the question is
this is compared to what harpers can do
what
what happened with it yeah it's not a
lord it's harvest bizarre you know but
then
vice harrison i think it was vanity fair
maybe
maybe it's vanity fair it's so like
yeah great you know first idea in the
think tank well i i think with camo they
had
more than more than uh
that's whack that's why that's i could
take that photo i mean that's
our old backdrop from the show
you know i'm glad to see that are back
to where are they now
the backdrop where are they now it's
such a good song on the cover of vogue
the cover the old backdrop from the show
is now on the cover of oh
congratulations rest in power
people hated our background
the uh yeah i don't i don't do you think
it's a black woman thing or you think
it's a style
thing i think it's maybe a trend thing
i don't think it started out as she's
black so let's go with our plan
c's and d's but i do wonder if there's a
subconscious
i don't know michelle has a lot of good
covers but that's michelle
i mean if we're talking about race she's
as black as she's black
as black as anybody something tickled me
um no i don't think it's black bad cover
white good of course there are good and
bad covers without everybody i just
think
people were saying there's a bit of an
absent mindedness to
like highlight her and get creative and
do something
spectacular i mean knowing samara like
she's not
she's incredibly thoughtful and proud of
but samia's not the one who decides the
photo
she's the editor of harper's bazaar and
style that shoot
she's one of the few people few exes who
did not like my tweet about
it being their fault oh really a lot of
people like a lot
a lot of it was a roll call for exes and
she
well maybe that one i don't think she
follows me maybe that one wasn't her
fault
uh she did what she did that wasn't her
fault
no it absolutely wasn't her fault um i
mean obviously the joke is it's not any
other
yeah no of course it's i'm woody allen
they're my dog
who who did what to whom do you know
this is just for my own uh goodbye
you've got hey bud so i'm
had some good things happening to me
recently and i began thinking about
legacy everyone wants a well-attended
funeral myself included
so what should i make a priority when
attaching my name to a thing
you hate legacy i don't care about
legacy i've been clear about this from
day one
yes i think it is hogwash
and i think once you're gone once it's
over it's over and this is
the spirit padres saying that you don't
believe in reincarnation
no but even if i did i wouldn't be like
you know that's my
former i built that gymnasium like
it's [ __ ] dumb it's just a dumb i'm
all for
giving but this thing of my
i shall and from here on out
people shall know the neil brennan name
that he stood for
it's the joke i've been doing about
confederate statues i wasn't
drawing strength from them the there's
what is there's a famous story about
there's like a statue somewhere in
england and
it's been so long no one actually knows
that's why knows why it's so [ __ ] fun
i mean it's it's a it's it's a it's an
allegory for all of it
it's hilarious or there's a there's a
rock in a church
that's been enclosed in like in a
display case
yeah and no one knows why it's a big
it's the dopest rock the the dopest well
he won
a rock of the century in 1400.
uh i don't care about legacy do what
you'd like
for your life question if you had kids
legacy helps other people that you're
when you're gone
not in a way that anyone likes i didn't
say money
i'm not i saved money i'm saying legacy
doesn't it help
your kids if you had kids that's another
thing i'm like
the name he's carrying on the name what
there's we have google now
i know what you were it's not like i
i've never heard of them in this town
what nick it's it's [ __ ] medieval
[ __ ]
come on come on don't waste my goodbye
you've got me here's an email
just letting you know big j and louis
louis j gomez recently said their last
conversation with patrice
o'neill was patrice talking about how
neal was one of his favorite comedians
[Music]
that's legacy nailed it
oh legacy when it comes to comedies like
well no it's
definitely said something about you that
was nice
uh i like that because
patrice and i had long arguments we had
a three hour argument one time on the
phone
that as soon as i hung up i was like i
wish i recorded that because it was so
emblematic of his personality where i me
and dov david offered doing a pilot we
wrote a part for him
and i called him and i was like and he
had done an episode of chappelle show
the player had his ball and then he just
wouldn't come back just wouldn't
wouldn't do it again would literally
didn't wouldn't come back
for what reason stubborn
i he didn't like supporting someone
he didn't like supporting them and he
didn't want to be in a he didn't want to
be like on
this motherfucker's show he wouldn't say
[ __ ] does he
did he ever have his own thing no so all
right so we have a three-hour argument i
start the conversation i go patrice
so me and doug have this thing for you i
go let me ask you this are you gonna be
an [ __ ]
he's like you know what the [ __ ] you
even calling me with this [ __ ] for like
what is that what the [ __ ] does that
even mean i go
wait that's how you open the
conversation are you going to be an
[ __ ] yes
i said hello probably but but also i
[ __ ] please
have you ever seen his comedy it's like
what that's how you yes that's
his [ __ ] lingua franca yeah okay um
uh i didn't just he didn't pick up the
phone and i said are you gonna
we exchanged things so we have a
three-hour argument about whether he's
an [ __ ] or not because i was like
patrice
he because he basically confessed to not
wanting to be on somebody else's show
uh i think that's probably why he quit
the office too because he was on like
the first exceptions of the office
um he was yeah heyman him and craig
robinson were like
a pair okay yeah um so
i asked him are you gonna be an [ __ ]
we argued for three hours
about what constitutes an [ __ ]
whether he'd be one
and i explained to him i was like
patrice when you're doing a tv show
it's so hard so when there's someone
around like you
who's like sucking their teeth and like
exhaling you want to kill the person
because you're so stressed out and
you're like flooded with
uh stress from having to do this job
uh and and he's and then at the end of
the conversation he's like you know what
neal
i can't promise you i'm not gonna be
nice
anyway so he talks about that in opiate
anthony and kindness
makes me sound like a [ __ ] right
okay two months later he up he calls me
and goes i owe you an apology
i go why he goes because i did a pilot
there was a kid on the set that just was
not
on board and i wanted to [ __ ] kill
him
uh and so i he he admitted he was wrong
and then another time he just called me
to say i was funny like
which was great and especially at
early in your when you're not haven't
been doing stand-up that long
everybody thinks your dave's hang around
uh it it helps if so if you ever
meet a young comedian who was the uh
writing partner one of the greatest
comedians ever be nice
be nice to him what do you guys want to
kill you be nicer
um goodbye you've got mail
[Music]
from liverpool england um
i don't think this subject isn't talked
about enough it's unlucky
what has happened to the girls there's a
video apparently what's going on
oh oh no we're not doing that sorry okay
next
well he did say something my question
okay
my question is okay so uh
my question is are we at the point of no
return
what could be the long-term effects of
the narcissism pandemic on society and
do you think
there is an unevenness in the balance of
narcissism between women and men
and why i reckon it's probably the
all the old 70 30 split in favor of
women
thanks for the great fun i reckon
liverpool
um so let's do the
i don't think that there i mean he's
basically just talking about social
media narcissism
yeah and he thinks it's monopolized by
women
i would argue that
it's closer than you'd think yeah
with men and the narcissism
twitter's narcissism i mean it's it's
not necessarily showing your tits it's
like
yeah it's not all material traditional
narcissism i think we can blame on women
more because we see it like
right but it's the same [ __ ] just comes
out different yeah it's like whether
you're uh
whether it's russian limbo saying i'm a
talent on loan from god
or or any just anyone blow v8 any i'm
[ __ ] blow vietnam twitter all the
time it's not
it's not uh coming from a good place
it's come and
also like how many likes i mean right
the economy of
likes is do you see that someone sent me
a video
of a woman
threatened her dog and the cops came
and threatened her it's the audience
looking but the cops come and they go
why would you threaten your dog and she
goes
for followers but not even thinking it's
crazy
like duh for followers
yeah she done it she did it on social
media
i don't think it's a woman this time
it's but there's
what was she doing she threatened a dog
on ig live i guess i i don't know
i don't i don't they just sent me the
video but
i don't think it's if it's worse for
women i don't think it's much worse
uh no i the amount of times i follow
this account called influencers in the
wild yeah it's
a [ __ ] it's one of the best ideas
that kid uh george tank sinatra
yeah it's such a good idea and
it's great i don't i want to be one of
those like i had that idea but i had the
idea that i saw him and i was like
it's so great it's and it got three
almost four million followers in like uh
six months yeah
guys uh i was uh early follower
and was not in the millions you're
welcome i bought the mixtape
um the he asked me to tweet about it
when he asked me to fund it i'm kidding
he asked me if i thought it was no it's
just a [ __ ] great idea
so i um there's guys on there
i've seen i always when i see people
doing videos i pull out my phone
immediately
it's so funny there was these two
japanese or korean kids at the beach
fully clothed doing a dance in sync
dancing is apparently is the most
impressive thing you can do
influencing the wild when they show you
the video that they took and then they
show you what they did to make it
i don't even look at them behind i just
look at the raw footage of like
them trying to do the backflip and the
behind-the-scenes yeah bts
yeah i never look at what they post
sometimes they'll
do a scroll yeah like oh look how good
it's so gross yeah even though we're all
like
at some point probably we're all doing
it i mean that's the
the thing is it's like well i'm not that
bad
you're not that bad this recently yeah
it's like dirty underwear
yeah did you see your underwear like
everyone has their numbers
you know no one wants they're dirty the
side note was
this is a neil name drop story come on
uh we haven't had one when will smith
did his
uh facebook thing and dave i was in it
and i think
mostly i might i don't i was in it dave
was in it it was he was there for david
i bumped it whatever
but we were all just talking [ __ ] for
like a half an hour
and q-tip came and then might have been
me might have been somebody else like
hey we should get
we should take pictures and everybody
was like yeah
will smith dave really cute everyone was
excited to get a picture for instagram
dave's usually not with other people i
know but it's will you know
yeah it's like everyone has everyone's
like hi
but it's so nobody it doesn't matter how
rich fame is
it's a new currency it's like bitcoin
from 10 years ago is
likes yeah like and you can buy
followers now you can buy likes so
we're doing pretty great guys goodbye
you've got hey thoughts and feels lstr
here and i would
it's nice never ask the pre-ayahuasca
nail and baking this but what are your
thoughts on manifestation
i personally think it's basically just
positive thinking and confirmation bias
but i'm wondering if you have any
particular feelings about it since
your ayahuasca journey do you think
people are able to manifest better
things or relationships for themselves
um p.s bianca you have looked especially
beautiful last few podcasts
drop your skin routine your skin care
routine
okay okay i but i would like to say i
told you how beautiful you looked last
week you did
you didn't say it this week hair
what
i didn't think i don't uh
you don't look as good this week as you
look last week i think you look pretty
good
well this is your megan the stallion
cover
okay it's paired down think of you know
what
taking a poll i think i looked i think
you just looked better last week it just
like
you like out you like out tear i think
you know you like me without hair yeah
yes
i do most women i like it back you
cover your face
um manifestation uh i don't know i
believe that
i truly like okay for example i won a
bachelorette to
mexico and one of the girls i didn't
know really well you're going on
you went on a bachelor i went i'm not
going i would not announce that
okay i'm not
and she was a a
grumpy gus a complainer everything she
complained about she complained about
essentially i'm like why did you come to
mexico it's not america
everything was wrong she ordered
weird drinks that didn't exist a mango
mango rita a mango lotta
everywhere she went i was like [ __ ]
they don't understand that
she was always complaining before we got
somewhere
complain the whole time complained after
but
all of her food came [ __ ] up all of
her orders came messed up
like things that would annoy regular
people like her orders were always the
last
we made her drink always was miswritten
down
and gave to her completely incorrect i
don't know part of me thought
lighten up like you know i feel like she
attracted
there is something too i've been in
it's like those days where just
a bird is more likely to [ __ ] on you
yeah on you based on your mood or
something
yeah i don't know it's something i don't
think it's manifesting
but i think it's some it's like it could
be a coincidence it might not be
it feels like that conan brosnan you're
not an innocent man a lonely man
yeah yeah yeah we're just always bad
it's a movie a simple man
a civil man it's about the bible it's
it's about like something you want to
talk about
brothers off year movies that they do
that goes in with
inside lou and dave
go [ __ ] yourself for telling me that's
your favorite movie
it's insane just love it no you don't
what
it never gave a payoff the music was
great
nothing happened the myths people tell
themselves
i just mean you know isn't there
something about attracting
i i don't know i mean i think like if
you look at your own life
and you look at the some things
feel weirdly like pre-ordained or
something and then some
i was always really into sketch comedy i
was always really into sketch comedy and
one-man shows
i don't know if i man you know whatever
i don't know
that's or is that just passion and
thought that's what i mean is it kind of
the
what is it the batter mine hop thing
where you know or if you're really open
to like i know friends like i always get
parking mm-hmm
and they do always find a spot they
always get parking is it
like you know they used to call it in
the 70s the kojak spot
really the
the kodak spot was is the spot right in
front of the store because that's
the tv show kojak whenever he pulled up
to investigate you know
it's it's a [ __ ] point yeah it's
really fun some of these people were
fine yeah they were fine
they smoked grass then they all they had
a firearms
problem p the shootings in the 70s and
peak is 1980. really gun handgun
violence in america
you wouldn't think it it's 1980 anyhow
anywho um yes i don't know
i but you're right there are people like
i always
upgrade right and they do yeah
maybe i don't know if you also it's a
little fake until you make it if you
just say it
kind of does i don't know i but i don't
think people would think to say i always
like the one like they wouldn't
think to do it beforehand it has to have
happened
it has to it might be you're drawing a a
false conclusion
that's entirely possible or you just
concentrate on the times where it works
out and you're not really looking at the
times where you don't find a [ __ ]
spot
you don't remember them yeah you don't
remember that they don't fit the
narrative so you just like that the lies
we
tell us it's the the myths also
skin care routine my friend brook davard
has a podcast called naked beauty
podcast i went on there
told my whole routine it's a lot and she
has the
best skincare recommendations for any
thing
anything you get going on she's like
it's a very good
skin beauty podcast i put almond oil on
my face
and in his car and everywhere i need
wherever almond
oil is and
and i sit in the sun now for 15 minutes
every day and i'm so pale that it shows
vitamin d banks long time lsd er back in
2019 you took my email on the pod
regarding my new long distance
relationship neil said he wanted to bet
me that it wouldn't last
and bianca said i was living in a
fantasy world
we're pretty great people uh that was
definitely us uh well our plans come to
fruition and
uh we have been living together since
march of 2020 the pandemic
made us speed up our plans with school
and work become a remote
she's great we're great i guess i got
extremely lucky in finding someone that
actually claims
actually calms my anxiety and has helped
me cope with uh mental health issues
as we moved in together something i
feel rarely happens anyhow with you
being a newly appointed spirit padre
neil and bianca is your spirit
apprentice not true
has ayahuasca changed your mind on ldrs
or relationships in general would you be
more open to dating a woman
who you met in a someplace far away no
uh no
some things are not going to change
tried and true it's good for you
also good for you for
now and also
you made it through and then you you
helped yourself by
speeding it up it's no longer an ldr
yeah they live together yeah
no so and we always said that hey if
there's
ever a plan to live in the same town
that's fine it's the no because i knew
someone who
uh just met and then he had to and they
were dating
very briefly and then he had to move for
school for a year
and then they just kept it going move
back married kids
so yeah if there's if there's if there's
like uh stopping a starting point
that's just like if a girl was like hey
can i stay with you for a month until my
until my apartment is ready or to my
house
that's not really moving in with you you
know right so this is not really the you
guys made it work
but the indefinite don't know who knows
death trap singaporean girlfriend
it won't work you know it won't work
goodbye you've um
got mail hey neil z and memph [ __ ]
give it a swing and a mess swing in a
minute
um big fan of the show i just turned 38
my current relationship has at the two
year mark hit a wall that seems to be
a recurring theme for me balancing
career ambition with you know being in a
relationship
i'm a creative in the entertainment
industry um
and my partner like many before her
feels neglected as i'm constantly
in self-employed creative mode don't get
me wrong i'm not a sociopath
like like the great filmmaker woody
allen but
not a big fan of traditional leisure and
place my creative goals as a high
priority that often results in me having
to say no to her
beginning to wonder if operating like
this is sustainable for me
as i also crave partnership and want a
friendship or want a relationship
i don't want to be unhappy and feel
lonely when i've been
single i don't want her to be half when
i've been single but i am trying to
uh have my cake and eat it too i don't
know what the [ __ ] he's asking
what i'm basically saying what should he
do um
i don't i mean i don't think a
relationship is right for him
if you that if you can find a one i
think he's saying
he wants one but but you don't want it
as much as the other
thing you want the other thing more so
that's the thing is like what should a
guy like that do
i think there are people who can find
balance or like
there's a lot of women who don't want
traditional relationships either
you wouldn't know it talking to neil but
well they don't come around me
it's a law of attraction thing okay
but so many women out here are not
looking for anything okay
there are bianca they're i know they're
i don't think that they don't exist
i just think that the numbers are in my
favor
maybe but i don't know yeah but i think
when guys are really forthcoming and
honest
girls are also honest too like if a guy
from on first date is like i'm not
looking for anything serious
most women aren't gonna try to make it
work i did a joke this weekend that did
so well come on laid on me that
men and women when we meet each other a
man will say
i'm not looking for anything serious and
a woman will say
i'm not looking for anything physical
and we both think to ourselves
we'll see yeah everyone does
because it's [ __ ] that's the very
good
you know every once in a while you know
patrice was famous
but i told you that i went on a date
with a guy and he was like i'm not
i just got out of something i'm not
looking for anything serious after our
date he asked me to go out again i said
well you you're really clear about your
boundaries and i'm more open than you
i'm not necessarily gunning for
something but i'm not closed off to it
and so yeah thank you for being clear
but
you know i don't know if it's right that
we go on another date
and then he won't stop calling me right
so what uh well that's just it's like
dangling
he wants to make love to your vagina
right but if someone's like i don't want
a casual hookup
and then you're like he was like no i
really like you i know well that's just
a guy
what what do we want to tell ourselves
it's a myth it's he's reading it it's
after six months
you're this is after six months it's
like
this is not good for your bottom line of
having sex
casually yeah don't bother me yeah
so i do think no matter if it's men or
women it's almost like
if you're dangling someone away from
some something away from someone and
saying well you can't have it because
everyone gets a little maybe i'm special
yeah i don't
i'm i don't i this is a that's almost a
separate
issue which is how do you balance how do
you
as a guy in showbiz and
whatever like that pretty much
every guy i know his first priority is
his career
yeah and and also the women i would say
that that work on their career
yeah that are that have a good career or
that that are like
building toward having a good career
that's their priority
uh so you either have to find somebody
who's okay with that
or you have to lie to them
and i suggest
let's move on will okay uh no i don't
and i don't know how you find that
i don't know will come on let's get out
of here well whose side are you on
and the segment well um yeah there's no
there's it's it's hard to find someone
who as someone once said
no one grow no little girl grows up
wanted to be dreaming of their husband
no
little girl dreams of being uh the third
most important thing in their husband's
life
true that so what do you do
goodbye you've got i know a long time
active lscner first time emailer that's
nice
and also the first person to make it an
active lsc in er
which is pretty great i think it's going
to be pretty great for us
what child's preferred way to insult
someone without using curse words
it's easy to call anyone a dumb
[ __ ] but i'm wondering if neil
has any old man singers
bianca you're you multilingual queen i'm
curious if you
any go-to non-english insults uh mine is
currently
calling fool's dodos i'm a fan of ding
dong
but i i really put this question in here
because i wanted to hear if you have any
foreign um okay
vietnamese kumkum ding ding ding ding
hong kong which is
it means crazy crazy stupid stupid by
the way that's how you
that's what you were calling sunyi
earlier you were calling it like some
home
or something that was soon you didn't
call her suny the first couple times she
said
really yeah you called her come come
ding dong i didn't say that
um okay swing in a minute ding ding dong
um farsi well it's not very nice uh you
can say
um uh you can say
well no it's kind of funny what's not i
don't want a no no no i'm thinking
so in persian culture the curse words
and the insults are
way worse if you say this
it's we have to fight there's nothing so
is it actually worse or it's just worse
in that culture um koskash
means you're a [ __ ] poker what does
that mean like your dick's not big
enough
no it just means cause casually you like
fingering it's just
i don't know you [ __ ] poker [ __ ]
because if that's the case
call me a [ __ ] poker okay
uh pimp in farsi is not pimping
it's rude it's like you take advantage
of women you're
disgusting whereas here that's couldn't
be further from the truth
well by the way that's what pimping is
anyway it's [ __ ] sex trafficking
yeah but uh here we like it's
dumb that we've made sex trafficking at
all that was
i would always make that obligation like
you know they're a pimp is a
sex trafficker it's cool
um uh let's see in german
what did we say um i don't know
what's a good thing in german i'm not
sure
maybe i mean like they have the same
things as us they have kind of
phrases like if you're if you think
you're really [ __ ] clever
and you're not they call you a jew okay
no what the hell you're juden you didn't
and now you didn't sorry
um i've never said it i've only read it
endlessly in my eyes as i could
where is my book of night myths
bianca honey there's a phrase what is it
um
have you eaten a clown for breakfast
really
has to encounter guessing what does that
mean
like oh you're so [ __ ] funny did you
eat clown for breakfast i
then i don't i don't mind that um yeah
little things little things
uh my favorite word in all languages and
is in hebrew
cover your ears cover yours it's sababa
because it means everything you don't
need to know hebrew it's negative it's
like no
anything like do i look fat in this
dress it's barbara you going to the
party tonight
sababa like everything is obama
and is it negative no it's like it's all
good whatever
it's aloha
it's aloha hawaii's got a bit of an
attitude with that aloha what do you
mean like you know it's a means
hello and goodbye okay cool
but they keep bringing it up like i know
it's not that interesting
i'm sorry i've got my state beefs are
coming out today
that's so good neil's so petty he's
petty about
states that's how petty i am
um uh what's up neil bianca
and they are active listeners since day
one etc etc
uh neil last week you mentioned dating
an avoidant woman and how you spent most
of your time confused and wonder if she
even liked you
i don't know uh if this i didn't know
this was a thing until you mention it
now i'm
in my current situation makes me make so
much sense
uh i've been seeing an avoidant woman
for about three months and
it's indeed confusing and i can never
tell her tell if she's into me but she
keeps showing up
uh can you say more about my experience
no no
you just they show up and you don't you
can't
look to them for warmth
or care what do you mean they'll have
sex with you
avoidance yeah oh yeah yeah so look
at him over um
and um but yeah you can't
you can't look to it for the normal
trappings what are the normal droppings
neil
it's like being at cheesecake factory
but they don't give you the vibrator and
let you know when your table's ready
you just have to so you gotta ask
you gotta ask please write that that's
so you just
you're like here's my different you're
like oh yeah it's been ready well
why not give me a vibrating i don't know
i don't want to give you that
that's what being with an avoidant woman
is like so
funny well that's your cheesecake
factory i love it
great analogy thanks every once in a
while so good patrice's
um patrice you see that do you wrap it
up patricia's do the joke uh
um uh i
i've been with my girl uh
a year she's been with me for three
that's a clean one that's a clean yeah
it's [ __ ]
so funny it's like yeah it's he's
patrice has about 10 jokes that are like
boeing uh
anyhow oh you know what i was going to
say if you want to send in new artwork
for the show
do because it's fun to get if you feel
like it uh yeah can we no
i you know it's funny but i'm a little
beaver claymation fantastic on our
sure um so make bianca more beautiful
just make sure i have glasses and um and
an ice cream
and i don't have to have ice cream i'm
just joking it i don't have to
uh look would it be nice of course um
and
uh and we don't i guess we just don't
have to take this [ __ ] yes we don't
goodbye
[Music]
[Music]
uh
tell me